How big of a role does your age play when
it comes to entrepreneurship?
Think about that.
That is probably one of the most common questions
I get asked all the time.
On Snapchat, on Facebook, on Cyberdust, on
Twitter - Pat, I'm 18 years old, how old do
I need to be to be an entrepreneur?
Hey Pat, do you think I can still be a strong
entrepreneur?
I'm only this age.
I'm only that age.
What is a good age?
So today I want to us to process if you can
be a good entrepreneur and a successful entrepreneur
being young, whatever age you are, and what
are real benefits of being an older entrepreneur
vs. a younger entrepreneur.
And then at the end I'll give you some of
the stereotypes younger entrepreneurs get
that's going to be your enemy if you're watching
this, and you're younger.
Your enemy is going to be these few things
I talk to you about and then we'll go from
there.
So here's what it is.
An older entrepreneur vs. a younger entrepreneur
-- does age really matter?
Older people are typically more paranoid.
That helps in business because when you're
older, people have stolen from you, lied to
you, given you some deals that didn't go through,
a bad partnership, bad relationship, so you're
paranoia is higher, and that typically helps
in business.
When you're younger, you're more naive.
You think the world is a great place, you
believe world peace exists and everything
can be nirvana and utopia exists, all this
stuff.
Not fully.
I'm not saying everybody.
Because there are some kids that grew up in
some cities -- if you grow up in Boston and
L.A. and South side Chicago - if you grew
up in some places, New York, Bronx, some places
you grow up, you're going to learn about being
bullied and pushed around so you'll have that.
But generally, younger is going to be more
naive.
Older is going to be wiser.
They've had more mistakes.
They've seen things.
Younger think they know it all.
Right?They think they know everything.
Totally fine.
Stay with me.
Older have more contacts.
Younger it's really only family, friends,
and teachers.
But older they have a lot more contacts.
Older is more logical.
Younger is more emotional.
Older have lots to lose.
So the decision making process is different.
Younger they have nothing to lose, right?
So when you ask the question who is more capable,
you have to look at these things.
And by the way, there's a lot more things
I can add to this list but I want to keep
this video very, very simple.
But I want you to think about it in a completely
opposite way.
So right now the way that I'm explaining it,
it's more beneficial to be older and be an
entrepreneur, right?
Well, is it really?
Because think about this.
There is some level of naiveness that's actually
not bad for business.
Why?
Because there's a certain level of optimism
to think that people are going to help you.
So you're willing to ask people for help.
Where this person is like, "oh, they'll never
help us.
Oh, they won't be interested.
They won't want to do anything."
You're [the younger] are like, "They will
help us!
Why wouldn't they help us!
Of course they'd love to team up!
Who wouldn't want to do something like that."
That's the child-like naiveness that's necessary
for business.
While this person [the older] is wiser, and
you [younger] think you know it all, right?
The younger generation may think they know
it all.
"Oh, you know what, sometimes these younger
people, they think they know everything!"
Is it really that they think they know everything,
or is it really something that they think
everything is possible?
Because I don't think it's really the younger
generation thinks they know it all.
They just think it's more possible.
Now, this notion we always hear about is what?
They think they know it all.
They're clueless.
They're kids.
No, no, no, no, no.
What you're really saying is you don't believe
it's possible and they think it's possible.
Maybe the older entrepreneur and the older
generation needs a little bit more of possibility
thinking that the [younger] inject into us.
Next one, contacts.
They [older] have more leverage for contacts.
You [younger] don't have that many contacts.
That part is absolutely true.
However, older people again, are more reluctant
to ask for help than younger people are.
The younger don't care.
By the way, if you're watching this right
now, and you are under the age of 23, 24,
25, and you have teachers, professors, coaches
that like you, family members, uncles who
like you -- let me tell you what script will
work for you, pretty much 60 - 70% of the
time.
Are you ready?
I need your help.
Done deal.
Auntie, I need your help.
Mom, I need your help.
Dad, I need your help.
Hey coach, I need your help.
Hey, teacher, I need your help.
Hey, counselor, I need your help.
Hey, you played such a big role in my life,
I need your help.
Your best friend's parents who really like
you, I need your help auntie, can you help
me?
I'm trying to be an entrepreneur and I'm trying
to be a business, I really need your help.
Can you help me?
You should introduce me to this person here.
Hey, I'm serious about wanting to do this,
I'm going to make an impact with my life,
I need your help.
Keep using that script because it works to
your advantage.
The older people get, they don't need help.
I know what I'm doing, I don't need anybody's
help.
It is a very, very big mistake in business
when people no longer want to ask for help.
Next, logic [older], emotion [younger].
You know what sells?
Emotion sells.
Now, you've got to definitely be looking at
the logical sides of business, contracts and
all that other stuff, but emotions sell.
Emotions speak here [the heart].
Logic speaks here [the head].
Okay?
Opportunity sometimes everything they go through
and want to look at the numbers and all this
stuff?
Yes.
Logic.
Like, for instance, if you're dealing with
venture capital and you're dealing with money
people, they don't care about how emotional
you are about your stores.
You've also got to know your audience.
If you're purely logical, what is the highest
possibility of doing something, what's the
numbers, what if this grows, what if that
grows?
Okay, we'll give a quarter million bucks at
10%, whatever.
That's how they'll work.
So if you're younger and watching this, don't
expect the investors to be too emotional with
you -- they're not.
But there are a lot of benefits to being emotional.
Next, nothing to lose [young], lots to lose
[older].
Just so you know, this [nothing to lose] is
your edge.
This is your edge, if you're watching this.
This is a very big edge, when you have nothing
to lose.
Who is the scariest person to fight in the
streets?
The person that's got two kids and a wife,
or the person that's got nothing?
They're by themselves.
Nothing to lose.
Who does the CIA hire by the way?
Think about that.
What is the pedigree of the people CIA and
the FBI like to hire?
Do you know what it is?
You know what it is?
Not married, not good with parents or parents
are dead, no siblings, no kids, no nothing.
Why?
There are no ties.
You have nothing to lose.
So you make a better CIA agent.
You make a better FBI agent.
Why?
Because of that.
The world of entrepreneurship is similar.
If, you know, sometimes some people that have
a house, I have this.
. . I can't lose all this stuff.
What if you do lose all this stuff?
What if you do end up losing all this stuff?
That's their [the older] challenge.
This is not your [the younger] challenge.
Now, if you're watching this and you're saying,
Pat, so who's side are you taking?
I'm not taking anyone's side.
I'm simply being an attorney for them [older]
if I'm representing them, and I'm simply being
an attorney for them [younger] if I'm representing
them.
I'm not taking sides.
I'm just telling you what your leverage is
here.
Now, I will tell you, the younger and the
older entrepreneurs here that are watching
this - when people ask does age matter, I
want you to know something.
I don't care if, like the other day, I was
listening to this kid play piano.
10 years old.
Oh my gosh.
He played piano, and I'm listening to this
kid - it was insane how he played the piano.
I couldn't believe how he played the piano.
Now keep in mind, I'm three and a half times
his age.
He's 10 years old.
Playing the piano.
Does age matter in the world of piano?
No.
It has nothing to do with anything.
So if somebody wanted to teach the other person
about playing the piano, who's going to teach
you?
The 10-year-old teaches me.
Why is that?
So let's dissect that a little, let's break
that down a little bit.
Why?
Age, and time in service, again, time in service,
not age.
What does that mean?
She's been playing the piano for six years.
I've never played the piano.
She's the expert.
I'm not.
She teaches me.
I listen.
Okay?
Not the other way around.
I listen to what she's telling me.
It doesn't matter how old I am.
I don't even know how to read the keys on
the piano.
She's going to be able to teach me.
She's the expert.
The same exact principle goes in the world
of business.
So if you're younger, if you're 14, 15, 16,
17, 18, 19, 20.
. . whatever the age is, between 14 and 25,
I don't care what age you are, okay if you're
younger, these are the couple of things you've
got to keep in mind.
#1: Your criticism you get for the younger
generation is lack of discipline.
Is lack of discipline.
So you've got to work on your discipline.
They [older] typically have more discipline,
because a lot more is on the line.
You typically have less discipline because
not a lot is on the line.
To you, if it doesn't work out, it doesn't
work out.
So I, as the customer need to be able to trust
your discipline, that you're going to come
through, and you're going to deliver, and
you're serious about it.
You're not just going to go home and fool
around with it.
So I watch discipline.
#2: Delivery.
If you say you're going to deliver, deliver
on time.
If you say you're going to deliver on whatever
promises, deliver on it.
Don't just say it, deliver on it.
Memory, remember things, remember things to
have an edge.
Next, product knowledge.
Know everything about whatever you're selling.
Everything.
Whatever you can, immerse yourself in that
product.
Just absolutely get obsessed about learning
every single thing about that product, history,
stories, facts, stats, everything you can
about the product.
Again, I don't care what it is.
Every single thing about that product, you
immerse yourself in.
So when you come and you talk to me about
your product and I say, "That guy knows what
he's talking about.
That's very impressive."
So here's what I'm willing to do.
I'm going to help.
I can do this for you sir.
And I can do it for you for this much money.
. . here's my contract, let me just tell you
who my contract is, my contract is through
my . . . we're doing this, this, this.
Great, no problem.
I see discipline, I see product competency,
I see respect, I see someone that's behaving
the proper way, no problem, great, let's do
business.
Okay?
No problem, great, let's do business.
And then last but not least, which is one
of the biggest criticisms the younger generation
gets is what?
Laziness.
I mean, I can't tell you how many times you
hear, "Oh, the younger generation doesn't
know about hard work."
Maybe they're right.
So guess what you should do?
You should work very hard.
The younger generation, they're so lazy.
They know nothing about hard work.
I remember when I was their age, I had 17
different jobs.
You know all those stories you hear about?
A part of it is right.
Maybe they were more hard working than today,
because today there is social media, there's
a lot more distractions, so if you're watching
this, and you're saying, "you know, my dad
would always say this and I'm 18 years old,
and my dad is 44 years old.
I'm so sick and tired of hearing that from
my dad.
Well, there's a part of what your dad is saying
that is right.
There was no Facebook.
There was no Twitter, there was barely Internet.
We still listened to music on tapes.
That's how crazy it was.
You've probably never seen a Walkman in your
life before.
We grew up, we didn't have phones.
If you had a cell phone, you had to be wealthy,
to have a cell phone.
Not everybody had a cell phone.
It wasn't something that everybody has had
a cell phone.
So what do I mean by that?
Here's what I mean by that.
Work double time.
Work triple time.
Outwork anybody that's your competitor, you
outwork them.
Anybody that's your competitor, you outwork
them.
And once you do that, no one's going to ask
you how old you are.
I'm sorry, how old are you?
19 years old?
I don't do business with anybody below 25.
No one says that.
No one's going to say that.
They're not thinking in their mind how old
you are.
In their mind they're thinking how much do
you know, will you deliver, will you keep
your word, are you hard working, do you know
everything about this product?
Let's do business.
That's all they care about.
You fit those few needs and you have this
[the items on the younger side], you've got
an edge on the older marketplace, who is also
trying to become an entrepreneur, and build
a business for themselves, and take away your
market that you have clients away from you,
but you've got to play to your strengths.
If you do that, you've got a shot at being
an entrepreneur.
So, with that being said, we're trying to
get to 100,000 subs, I think right now we're
at 75,000 subs, if you have not subscribed
to this channel, please be sure to do so.
Click on the link below here to subscribe
to channel, and if you've got any questions,
thoughts, comments, you can always --
so subscribe to this channel if you haven't
yet.
This channel will get to a million subs, but
our next major milestone is to get to 100,000
subs.
And we have some major plans to teach entrepreneurs
all over the world about how to build a business
for yourself -- around the world, from 196
countries follow this channel here.
So subscribe.
And if you've got any questions, comments,
comment on the bottom.
If you're not following me on Snapchat either
and you want to ask me a question, it's a
lot easier for me to also snap back, you can
always follow me on Snapchat, Betdavid19 is
the username, and this is what my Snapchat
code is, you can follow me right there.
With that being said, thanks for watching
everybody, take care, bye bye.